if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is
[Music]
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once gummy
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are uh
this is a very very special stream
uh i don't know why but it just is
we have so much to talk about in advance
of the joe biden town hall that is
happening tonight
i was initially planning to stream later
and to cover the town hall
itself i have been warded off of doing
that
uh it's a bad idea facebook is a
non-starter anything on cnn
facebook you will just be beaten down
into a bloody pulp
uh twitch was a probably not and then
i was told youtube also bad idea you
will get shut down
very hard the idea of course of um
uh you know the presidential speech
being protected by copyright is
kind of a question mark but in any case
we're doing a
early and early stream an historic early
stream i have
two four six i have about uh
12 things to go over with you i may take
phone calls we have unban requests
inconsolable has gifted 20 subs on
twitch already i mean it's a crazy crazy
day so i'm really glad to be back
and there is um a lot to discuss where
to start though
i was hoping to make it while newsmax
was still talking about
how the media and biden have a
codependent relationship
which is hilarious because newsmax and
oan
only exist to the degree that they are
now slightly more prominent
because they rode trump's coattails if
i've if i've ever seen a co-dependent
relationship
it is newsmax and oan with donald trump
so we will get back to newsmax but i
have a bunch of other things to look at
uh where do i even start i want to make
sure i provide time for people to get
into the stream and there's just a lot
of different things going on
let's look at a couple of super chats
chaka seki says trump may think
nancy pelosi is as crazy as a bed bug
but this 911 style investigation
might peel the years of tanner off of
his skin
maybe so and storm chaser says thoughts
on the texas power situation
i thought liberal states like california
were taking away our heating and
powerful flushing
4 million without power heat water sad
it is horrible what is going on in texas
and maybe we will get right to that
let me see where do i have this hold on
a second i have
a lot of elements related to that oh
here it is check this out
ted cruz this this guy is such a slime
ball
republican texas senator ted cruz
tweeted urgently today senator john
cornyn and i
sent a letter to president biden urging
for governor greg abbott's emergency
federal disaster declaration request to
be approved
amid severe winter storms across the
state of texas
this is the same ted cruz who in 2012
voted against
federal relief funds for hurricane sandy
to go to new
new york and new jersey 2012 voted no on
that
and then in 2015 he wanted federal money
for texas floods
and then in 2017 he wanted federal money
for what was it in 2017 hurricane
hurricane relief
in texas and then now he wants money
for the storm and power outage now to be
clear
of course they should get it of course
texans should get it
but this guy is just a disgusting
hypocrite who
seems to say give me give me the money
when
he uh when it relates to his own
constituents and here we actually have
this is an interview he did
i covered this so long ago this is an
interview he did with msnbc
um and katie tour katie tur
tried pointing out the hypocrisy and he
came up with something about pork
take a listen to this you're busy and i
want to let you get back to doing
everything you can out there
but a lot of people are pointing out
that you voted against
aid for sandy after that catastrophic
catastrophic storm
up in the northeast that package back in
2012
and they're they're pointing at you and
saying you're asking for money now when
you weren't willing to help the people
in the northeast what do you have to say
to them
well you know look there's time for
political sniping
later right the time for political
sniping is when
other people's constituents need the
money
the time for political sniping was when
it was new york and new jersey people
that needed money that was the time for
political sniping not now
can't you guys tell he's wearing a you
know he's wearing a jacket that
shows that he's helping i think our
focus needs to be on this crisis
these are people who needed money and
who needed funding right after that
storm i covered those people
many of them just like those in houston
lost absolutely everything they owned
well katie katie of course that's right
and and the accurate thing to say is
that i and a number of others
enthusiastically and emphatically
supported hurricane relief
for sandy hurricane relief and disaster
relief has been a
that's not true vital federal for a long
long time and it should continue
the problem with that particular bill is
it became a 50 billion dollar bill
that was filled with unrelated pork
two-thirds most of the pork put in there
by his
republican friends saying if you don't
put this stuff in here
we're not gonna we're not gonna vote for
this that bill had nothing to do with
sandy
and and what i said then and still
believe the one thing now
it's true that some of the money in that
bill i mean we're going back
nine years now but some of the money in
the sandy bill was not
for response to sandy but for
preparedness for the next
hurricane and republicans like ted cruz
at the time were saying
this is a way of sneaking in money for
leftist climate change ideas like
it to call it even to call a lot of it
pork
it's called let's prepare for the next
one it's sort of like right now we
should be spending money on
getting the pandemic response team back
in place this
he's just disgusting believe now is is
that it's not right for politicians to
exploit
a disaster and people are hurting to pay
for their own political wish list
there it is again so it's i it's i mean
i covered this
nine years ago i actually remember it
sorry
this is from this is from four years ago
his vote against sandy relief was nine
years ago
disaster relief needs to be focused on
the victims of disaster relief and
preventing future disasters i supported
that
for sandy disaster relief there and i
would support that anywhere there's a
major disaster
without getting getting distracted by by
political unnecessary pork spending yeah
so that's his justification four years
ago for his
uh blatant complete and blatant
hypocrisy
uh on uh on on funding for
uh response to and preparedness for
future
natural disasters he's he is a hypocrite
and he's a disgusting person i
completely and totally agree with you
okay very good so we've gotten that out
of the way
let me say thank you to jonathan carney
jonathan
carney is new member number one today
now i know we've not opened the phone
lines recently
i am more than willing in fact i would
love to open the phone lines today we
have a goal of a hundred website members
and twitch subs
we also did get thanks to inconsolable
gifting a bunch of subscriptions
we just got 23 twitch subs dumped out of
nowhere
which puts us at 24. all right and the
coupon code
it's working perfectly at joinpakman.com
before i get to some clips from fox news
from yesterday let me look at a few
other super chats
james montalbano says i get all my
morality from donald trump so should
biden be helping texas
even though they didn't vote for him
that by trumpian ethics
that is a reasonable question absolutely
uh still alive says think will get
answers
student loan forgiveness think we'll get
well do i think we'll get student loan
forgiveness i actually don't think so
i don't believe there will matthew davis
says fox news was just talking about how
what's going on in texas is a failure of
green energy instead of you know a
climate change issue
yeah let me see if i can even i saw that
aaron rupar
posted a few clips of that let me see if
i can find them here
uh let's see where was this texas
stuff why stimulus pending doesn't work
fouchy dating uh some
stuart varney stuff
yeah here it is mother nature freezes
biden's green climate agenda
i i don't have a clip here maybe
yeah i'm not i'm not easily finding one
let me see a couple of our other
clip sources on twitch no not here
either
oh no twitter rather yeah no i i know
exactly the segment you're talking about
but
i am unable to easily find
a a segment on that
uh okay very good so we're fine as far
as that
goes i have one people are asking about
voicemails and unban requests i have one
of each
do you guys want me to do the un twitch
unban request
or voicemail what do people prefer
i'll do both um i'm just glad to i mean
you know i'll do either first whatever
people prefer
the unban yeah all right let's do that
first okay so we've got a user i don't
for people who ask i don't put these up
on screen because i don't want anything
accidentally getting on screen
that um you know could get me banned
let's see here um
okay president snowflake
about joe biden that's okay
david always talking about his money
and then banned for possible
anti-semitism okay i understand that now
their unbanned request
is i'm very sorry i was stressed by
trump and drinking at the time
i plan to be more respectful and
productive in the chat
i'm gonna go ahead and grant that i'm
gonna grant that as an unban that's okay
um it's not clear that their comment
about money was uh
anti-semitic or anti-semantic and i'm
gonna go ahead and unban that's
reasonable we'll keep an eye on them
but that's a fair i'm i'm glad i
adjudicate that
and that's fine and then one
other unban request we're f'd
2020 watermark 2020 trump 2020 all back
to back to back
and then can i get an unban please trump
2024.
now we're going permanent on that that's
a deny
we're gonna that's that's just that's
just lame i mean listen they'll go and
make another account and be back
whatever but that's going to be that's
an a
and people seem to agree with that okay
good so
we're caught up big housekeeping stream
we're caught up as far
as um unban requests
go and now let's get caught up as far as
voicemails go
i did get a troy york voicemail i don't
know what it's about it came in in the
wee hours this morning let's take a
listen to it
see what it's about could be anything
david peckman this is troy troy york
watching down carlson he pointed out the
hypocrisy and the lies of the climate
change radicals who oh i
actually have this tucker segment to
review i haven't seen it use climate
deniers of
uh attempting to uh
stall progress of green technology and
the green movement but in reality as we
see in texas windows
and solar energy are unreliable energy
and now the people
2 million or 3 million people in texas
are freezing without
um electricity because of the
lies and the propaganda of the green
technology
he does sound sober this time i agree
people are observing that
demands of the democrat party the
radicals
who are funded from overseas and who
will these companies
uh actually benefits from transitioning
america from
fossil fuels natural gas to unreliable
windmills that can't even perform within
a little ice that kill massive amount of
birds
solar energy is not reliable how many
people are killed from fossil fuel
drilling
the bird thing has been widely debunked
at this point
i mean yes some birds are killed by wind
farms but consider
the death as a result of fossil fuels
not only you know cancer and people i
mean come on
uh okay let's listen to a little more
and this whole bogus lie of the democrat
party is a redistribution of wealth as
i've been saying for a long time
and you should watch tucker carlson's
10-minute program has he
if this all right well let's check it
out okay i had that pulled up let's
actually do that right now just to get
it out of the way
uh we'll watch it right now just so
happens i have it handy
i'll read a couple of other super chats
before we move on
um did i see this interview this is the
interview of a trump attorney ripping
their mic off we'll look at that as well
so i'll get to that matthew says forbes
had a green energy snipe piece too
not surprised owen is missing me in
pogchamps 3 will i ch
stream chess again in the future yeah
i'd like to i'm still playing
pogchamps 3 has been funny entertaining
very very entertaining
i was featured in a congratulations to
hikaru
million twitch subs uh twitch followers
sorry twitch followers video earlier
today
david perdue running against raphael
warnock 2022
i heard he was thinking of running i
didn't know if that he was
what's my opinion of the u.s sanctioning
german companies for nordstream 2
in the name of european energy security
uh i don't know enough about it yet to
be able to say all right so there's
super chats we're caught up as far as
that goes uh feel free to send them in
let's listen now to tucker carlson here
we go
oh hold on here we go good evening
welcome to tucker carlson tonight happy
monday well the green new deal has come
believe it or not to the state of texas
and we're here with the report how's it
working out so far well the good news is
all that alternative energy seems to
have had a remarkable effect on the
climate as intended
last night parts of texas got to
temperatures
that we see in alaska in fact they were
the same as they were in alaska
so global warming is no longer a
pressing concern in houston
we've solved that problem the bad news
is they don't have electricity
the windmills froze so the power grid
failed millions of texans woke up to
soil their water because with no
electricity it couldn't be purified
the ironically named electric
reliability council of texas which
oversees the grid
had no solution to any of this they
simply told people to stop using so much
power to keep warm
so this is already a lie okay
it is true that there were some wind
turbines
that froze that that is absolutely true
but all of texas's systems are
unprepared for the temperatures that
we're seeing
and the primary problem was actually
frozen instruments
at fossil fuel power plants at uh coal
plants
at um at natural gas plants
even at nuclear facilities so this this
is just a lie it's not you know the
the picture that they're painting is of
a texas
only relying on crappy little windmills
all frozen unable to move because of ice
it is true that the entire system
in texas at least south of certain parts
of the state
uh was not prepared for these
temperatures that is true
but a bigger problem than frozen
windmills with wind farms as we should
call them
um are frozen instruments at natural gas
coal and even
even nuclear plants so the i don't know
if the net you know troy york wanted me
to look at this i don't know if the next
eight and a half minutes are all based
on this false premise but so far
this is all this is all a lie let's
continue
so in houston hundreds of shivering
texans headed to the civic center like
refugees to keep from freezing to death
some people in texas almost certainly
did freeze to death today that's what
happens when it gets that cold
later this week we'll learn just how
many as they tried to keep warm with
jury rigged heaters and barbecues
i don't know why it's skipping like that
that's very weird car exhaust that
happens every time
when the power goes out even advanced
societies become primitive and dangerous
people die we've seen it happen
repeatedly in california for years now
rolling blackouts in a purportedly first
world state that is slipping steadily
into chaos
but in texas who saw that coming and not
just because
texas is mostly republican what's funny
is that when they say who saw that
coming
what they should really be saying is
climate scientists
have been saying for a long time that
climate change is not just it's really
warm
it's record highs and record lows
erratic weather
out of the out of the nine you know out
of the bell curve
so it seems as though if in texas
they believed the not believed accepted
the science
they would have said hey even though a
lot of texas doesn't usually get very
cold
we might want to have a system that
accounts for the fact that if climate
scientists are correct
it might get colder than we expect and
you would heart like it's not it's not
to blame you just have to get you have
to deal with it
obviously now and people are suffering
but when he talks about who would have
predicted it in texas
you would have listened whoa my chair
just did you see that my chair just went
down like five inches when um
if had they been paying attention to the
science they would have actually been
able to plan for this
if there's one thing you would think
texas would be able to do
is keep the lights on right most
electricity comes from natural gas and
texas produces more of that
than any place on the continent there
are huge natural gas deposits all over
texas
texas is an oil and gas state famously
running out of energy in texas is like
starving to death at the grocery store
you can only do it on purpose well they
they also didn't run
out of energy this is
if this is like the big indictment of
green energy
wow i mean this is so stupid and texas
did
rather than celebrate and rather fit
from their state's vast
natural resources politicians took the
fashionable route and became recklessly
reliant on so-called alternative energy
meaning windmills 15 years ago there are
virtually no wind farms in texas
last year roughly a quarter of all
electricity generated in the state
came from wind that's fantastic they
have they have the geography for wind
power that's great
local politicians were pleased by this
they bragged about it like there was
something virtuous
if that number is even true i don't know
actually about destroying the landscape
and degrading the power grid just last
week governor greg
abbott proudly accepted something called
the wind leadership award given with
gratitude
by a company getting rich from green
energy all right so it was all working
great
until the day it got cold out now why is
it worse to get rich from green energy
than from dirty energy like i mean
that's just a
it's a serious question if someone's
going to make money from energy
why is it worse if it's from the kind
that doesn't harm the planet
i i mean it's a serious question i don't
know the answer side
the windmills failed like the silly
fashion accessories they are
and people in texas died a lot more of
them than died at the capitol on january
6th by the way just for reference
now we're telling you all of this not to
beat up i mean a lot of people die from
gun violence that's preventable every
year as well tucker doesn't seem to want
to do anything about that
the state of texas it's a great state
actually but to give you some sense
about what's
about to happen to you to every state
we're not speculating on that
here's the new president explaining his
plan
in my view we've already waited too long
to deal with this climate crisis
we can't wait any longer that's why i'm
signing today an
executive order to supercharge our
administration's ambitious plan
to confront the existential threat of
climate change that is an existential
threat just reading the script
climate crisis existential threat
ambitious plan
you know i am i just finished up reading
the book merchants of doubt by
naomi oreski's and i forget
her co-author's name because i
interviewed her i think conway eric
conway
it's not dr eric coomer i think it's
eric conway
and it actually points out in great
detail
how all of this denial and doubt that we
now see
goes back about 40 years to a group
of basically it it comes down to
anti-regulation right-wingers
who who have the exact same blueprint
for introducing
doubt about uh is cigarette smoking
harmful
to your health and when they couldn't
deny that is secondhand smoke harmful to
your health
uh denying the ozone uh whole the uh
hole in the ozone layer stuff um
denying acid rain denying uh co2
it's the exact same playbook mostly
mostly motivated by either personal
financial opportunities
uh or by a broader and oh ddt
the pesticide ddt denying that it's
harmful to human health
it's the exact same playbook it's the
exact same playbook and it leads to this
and i don't even think i need to watch
any more of this so troy york wanted me
to watch this and said this was
like some big takedown the first 35
seconds tell you everything you need to
know which is tucker is blaming the
power outages in texas on windmills
the truth is that while there are some
frozen windmills there are
far more impacts from frozen
instruments at natural gas nuclear and
coal plants and that's really all you
need to know
the entire premise of this segment is a
lie so we did that
we did that we did the ted cruz thing um
okay we're getting to a lot of these
different things that we have
uh big thank you to lemmy lebro
remy lebro for the eight months on
twitch
i want to say thanks also to the other
six people a total of seven that grabbed
twitch subscriptions
we will open phone lines if we get to
100
and other new members to thank ooh
nobody yikes that is sad that is said
uh it's almost it's almost embarrassing
i think that's a cell phone
but feel feel free to grab a membership
at jointpakman.com would very much
appreciate it if you did we've got a
code better21
and that'll that'll save you bigly and
uh let's see if next time i check in on
it there's actually somebody to thank
i really that that is that is
embarrassing that is embarrassing
okay a few other super chats if
stupidity could be harnessed as a power
source
tucker could power the whole world by
himself
just blame antifa and move on tucker
your chair was obviously manipulated by
antifa
from the uk i have friends from texas
who won't hear a bad word about ted cruz
even when i state my case about his
disgraceful actions why
i don't know but it sounds embarrassing
here's a danger of fossil fuels there's
an epidemic of carbon monoxide poisoning
in texas due to people running their
cars and heaters inside that is
that is tragic and i read about that
ellis wants to know what i think of
nuclear power it has killed far
less far fewer people than other power
sources such as natural gas and
hydroelectric hydroelectric i don't know
about but yes on the others
i am not reflexively anti-nuclear like
many people on the left
uh we we have interviewed actual nuclear
power engineers on the program
um i believe that uh new nuclear
is so much safer than
what was being constructed 40 50 years
ago i think it is a concern
that it takes a while to bring new
nuclear capacity
onward uh online rather
and that would be a concern because if
it takes 10 12 years to do that
well 10 12 years from now we we already
should have made great strides to get
off of fossil fuels but
i am not reflexively anti-new nuclear
the waste is an issue as people are
pointing out in twitch chat for sure
but there are increasingly more elegant
ways
i guess i would call them to deal with
that
all right so that's my thought as of
right now
let's um let's continue
the fact that america has not even a
public option is embarrassing it makes
me legitimately sad yes
ironic all the wind turbines are in deep
red counties freezing here in texas
without power
can't even get mcdonald's because of
lines take the money i couldn't spend
i'm sorry to hear that sam that's really
horrible
really really horrible
okay let's let's see let's next go to
this interview where trump's lawyer rips
off his mic
i haven't seen this but i've heard about
it let's take a look has voted to acquit
former president trump of inciting
when did they get to the interview the
final senate vote was
curious joining me now is former
president trump's attorney
michael van der veen thank you sir for
joining us let's get right into
those words that we heard from senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell
he ended the trial with this this guy
has real drank the kool-aid vibes
in his speech about president trump's
involvement in the insurrection
during it he said that the former
president is still liable for
everything he did during his period in
office
are you expecting to face more charges
against mr trump in the near future and
do you anticipate being part of that
defense
no that's just political rhetoric and i
was hopeful that something would come
out of this
that the political rhetoric would stop
out of washington d.c but i guess
apparently it hasn't
okay were you though surprised to hear
those words coming from the leader of
the republican party in the senate
i'm not surprised to hear a politician
say anything at all
no well throughout throughout the trial
you denied that mr trump had a role in
inciting the january 6
insurrection at the capitol you what
what a guest huh expansive articulate
didactic
okay you argued first of all that there
was no insurrection
but during your closing arguments you
seemingly admitted that there was in
fact an insurrection
using that word saying that that that
was not up for debate
what role did the former president play
you didn't understand the case
i used the word i'll give you the
opportunity to clarify sir sure
i used the word insurrection my closing
argument when
quoting the charging documents
what happened at the capitol on january
6 is absolutely horrific
but what happened at the capitol during
this trial
was not too far away from that
wow the prosecutors in this case
doctored evidence
they did not investigate this case and
when they had to come
to the court of the senate to put their
case
on because they hadn't done any
investigation
they doctored evidence it was absolutely
shocking i think we're talking about
when uh when we discovered it's
incredible the casual nature with with
this which with
with which they say these things and we
were able to expose it and put it out
i think it turned a lot of senators
didn't turn anyone
didn't turn anyone if anything senators
were turned more republicans voted
guilty than was expected american people
should not
be putting up with this they need to
look at who
uh who these house managers were
and look to see whether these are the
folks they want representing them
it was absolutely shocking to me
wouldn't have believed
let's follow up with uh with a point
that you're making right now about the
house managers as you say doctoring
evidence and
uh and the arguments
what you're talking about now is is a
check mark
uh that's a verification on twitter that
that
did not exist on that particular tweet
uh a 2020 that should have actually read
2021
um and these sound like errors more than
anything to me
selective editing you say of of the
tapes is that how
wait wait
that's not what she said this guy's very
triggered respectfully
the media has to start telling the right
story in this country
he listen this guy knows everything
this guy knows how a senate should
handle an impeachment
this guy knows how the media is supposed
to do interviews
and report story we this guy should be
running every business
the media is trying to divide this
country
you are blood thirsty for ratings and as
such
you're asking questions now that are
already
set up with a fact pattern i can't
believe you would ask me
a question indicating that it's all
right just to doctor
a little bit of evidence she didn't say
that there's more stuff that we
uncovered that they doctored
to be frank with you and perhaps that
will come out one day
but we won this case and i'm not a sore
loser
but what happened or a sore winner i
should say
but what should happen is somebody
should look at
the conduct of these house managers it's
unconscionable
impeach them he says aside from all of
the due process violations that my
client had
and the media should be looking that at
a square straight way
the straight way when i watch the news i
watch one station
and it's raining i watch another station
at the same time
and it's sunny your coverage is so
slanted it's gotta stop you guys have to
stop
and start reporting more like pbs does
rather than uh uh i mean it's
interesting he mentions pbs because
people who are
uh who whose primary news sources pbs
are more informed uh and they
are a far more liberal than they are
conservative so it's interesting
to hear a mention pbs uh a
tv news show that he is out of his mind
yes that's true
doesn't have any journalistic integrity
at all
what i'm telling you is that they
doctored evidence
and i believe your question says well
it's only a twitter check and uh
and changing a year of a date here they
switch the date
of a twitter a year
to try to connect it to this case that's
not a small thing ma'am
the other thing they did is they put a
check mark on something
to to make it look like it was a
validated account
when it wasn't and when they were caught
they didn't say anything about it they
didn't even
try to come up with an excuse about it
and that's not the way
our prosecutors or our government
officials should be conducting
themselves
and the media shouldn't be letting them
get away with it either i'm tired of the
biased media
on both sides left and right what this
country wants
what this country needs is this country
to come together
to take the left and the right and find
a middle ground
and see that's the fallacy of the of the
center
that the right path is in the middle
uh often it's just not it's just not
it's it's a it's it's
fallacious to begin with start
responsibly
being our public officials our elected
officials
and the new and the re one of the
reasons why they do it
is because of the media because the
media wants to tell
the media narrative rather than just
telling it like it is
and frankly i'm tired of it i'm not a
media i'm not in front of your cameras
all the time
uh but i've been subjected to this left
stand
i understand and i've given you the
truth yeah
i've given you the opportunity i i it's
like he he's been speaking unintended
my chair went down again something
weird's going on with my chair i might
have to be replaced
i might have to do the entire show down
here um
he's been speaking uninterrupted for
like three four minutes
and he's furious that he's not allowed
to speak was that for our viewers who
have not been following
all of the hours of of this trial
to be clear about what you what you are
speaking about
and i understand speaking about the
house manager's failure to prove their
case
that's that that's what i'm telling you
they weren't able to prove their
acquittal
you have won the acquittal of your
client and if you'd like to continue to
talk
about this conversation we can have that
discussion
but uh but for me to ask a question
a slant a slanted question
he reminds me a little bit of brett
kavanaugh actually the question that was
set up to say
it's okay for them to cheat that was
your question
isn't it okay for them to cheat i did
just a little bit
you said to be fair it was only a check
that's what you said you got to live by
your words
that's the problem the media has to
start living by the truth
and not trying to create a narrative
michael vanderveen
thank you for joining us i i do
appreciate yeah
okay all right ooh he tosses them
yeah so he that guy he he actually does
seem um he seems completely out of his
mind yeah
that's absolutely true i've been stuck
with people like that at dinner parties
and it's bad really really bad like that
that personality type becomes very
weaponized
in a lot of uh social social settings i
want to say thanks to dean smith dean
smith just signed up at joinedpakman.com
don fulton signed up at joinpakman.com
alicia ramos signed up at
joinedpakman.com and
jason etheridge has signed up as well
very much appreciate that also want to
say thanks to the
eight additional twitch subscribers
putting us at 43 the phone lines will
open
at 100 and i would absolutely love it i
would
just so appreciate it if you signed up
at joinpackman.com
i will have coverage of this tomorrow
but donald trump in the last half hour
put out a statement i guess attacking
mitch mcconnell
um let's take a look at what he had to
say here
uh where is the actual letter oh i'll
have to find the exact the full thing
trump on tuesday unloaded on senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell and
vowed to back
challengers to lawmakers who have
crossed him trump's statement was
released
through his save america super pac
blames mcconnell
for the republican losses in 2020 trump
should be blaming himself
mitch is a dour sullen and unsmiling
political hack
and if republican senators are going to
stay with them they will not
win again trump lost the elect trump
lost
the white house for himself and trump
lost the senate for republicans and he's
he's blaming mitch mcconnell he will
never do what needs to be done
or what is right for our country where
necessary and appropriate i will back
primary rivals who espouse making
america great again
and our policy of america first we want
brilliant
strong thoughtful and compassionate
leadership
um yeah it's roughly what we would
expect right i mean
that's the type never taking
responsibility it's always someone
else's fault so it's in line with what i
would expect
i don't know that i have much to say
about it right now
that just released and we will uh cover
that
on tomorrow's show okay before we get to
the next things i had planned let me
just get caught up
on super chats here joe's quadcopter
videos
says i saw a business hanging a trump
2024 flag today
david i emailed you about this guy he's
a personal injury attorney like celino
and barnes or jim the hammer spiro
i'm not familiar with jim the hammer
shapiro
but that's funny he sounds just like
trump a total fraud
and emotional word user while ignoring
facts
it's sad this guy is being hailed as a
hero for sticking it to the media
because he said the word only
this is a tantrum not an adult yes
he was caught taking coasters from the
senate that's true
how close to 1.3 million subscribers are
you has the rate of increase
changed much much since the election i'm
glad you're here for us david
so the rate of change accelerated after
the election in november
and december and then slowed down a
little bit
we are only 8 000 subscribers away from
1.3
million 1.3 million
so that is all very very good news
achaka seki says trump would have had a
better defense if he hired gritty
rather than this hoagie-filled bozo i
don't know who gritty is
chakaseki often with cultural references
that i lack
i thought they made a point with the
accusation of falsifying evidence what i
saw these changes in the evidence were
never addressed what are your thoughts
i'd have to look into it more quite
frankly i don't know much about it
skitoshi nakayobro says doctored
evidence we all watched it live bro
okay it seems the republican party is
eating itself do you think this will
hurt them i think it will yeah
tristan says not just out of his mind
but extreme passive aggressive
toxic personality bronx bjorn says just
saw fox news article
trump palm beach bustling new york city
ghost town
i live in new york city what are they
talking about yeah that's a new
narrative that they're telling where
they are
um they are praising governor ron
desantis for just opening everything
um that's that's basically the whole
story
thanks to ari milillo i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly
thanks ari for signing up at
joinpakman.com
okay let's keep going i have many other
things planned
uh this is a this is a funny post
from our subreddit now i've talked
before about the unsubscribed trolls
these are people who were never actually
subscribed
who very dramatically announce that they
are unsubscribing from the show and very
often it's just totally fake
but then we also do have people who
unsubscribe for what i would consider
really
kind of kind of toxic reasons anyway i
saw a headline on the subreddit which
was i unsubscribed from the channel
today and i thought oh god not this
again but it's actually really funny
so i was watching the senate trial live
stream a few minutes ago trump's lawyer
was rambling with some bs argument
needless to say i was tired of it
i decided i wanted something more in
depth something with more commentary
something with more pac-man
so i tried clicking on the channel icon
to go to his page and find another video
unfortunately unfortunately i
accidentally hit the unsubscribe button
i was shocked
and urgently resubscribed david i'm so
sorry i failed you
and hope you can forgive me i promise it
was an accident
and i'll never make that mistake again
so i appreciate that i thought that was
going to be another one of these
really toxic unsubscribes one other
funny post
um this people people really came up
with some funny stuff on this one
torcancum tortancum posted
i want to call into the show just so
that david can ask me if i've been to
some obscure restaurant
in my home city inspired by david asking
that woman
if she's been to the vietnamese food
stall in a market in montreal
it was actually a cambodian food stall
and i find it really offensive that you
would mistake
cambodian and vietnamese food that's
really really mean
but then people came in with a lot of
other funny stuff
i want to call the show so i can pretend
to be flustered and surprised that he's
asking me what i want to talk about
and then meandering my way through a
really oddly
and poorly thought out question i want
to call in so i can test the feed delay
by having his show run in the background
that's a classic
i want to call the show so i can show
off
about how many notifications my phone or
laptop gets
in just two minutes i want to call the
show from outside the u.s to ask david a
very specific question
about politics in my country providing
no explanation or context to why it's
relevant
about which he couldn't possibly have
any informed view
yeah i there was i love all the callers
you all know that but i got a funny one
a couple of weeks ago
where someone called in and asked it was
something about um
some specific education policy in
switzerland and like i'm sure it's
really important
but i don't i don't you know i i don't
know about everything that's going on
unfortunately um i want to call in and
actually be in a wind tunnel as a power
move
i'm going to call from a steel mill in
vienna so he's irate about the noise but
is too interested in what restaurants
i've tried to hang up
i've never been to vienna so i wouldn't
be able to uh
talk about that um
okay all right good so we got that very
good we've got that out of the way
next thing i have here
i've been asked to review this
anti-masker arrest now we've reviewed a
bunch of these
and some of them are pretty edgy some of
them
are not uh i know that this one is is
like
a two weeks old i've not seen it okay
i've not seen it so i'm up for taking a
look at it
but first let me just say thank you to
kristen holmes kristen holmes just
signed up at joinpakman.com
appreciate that also big thank you to
super nintendo
the strawberry rodeo and nene
for signing up via twitch that puts us
at 48.
if people would like the phone lines
opened
just sign up at joinpakman.com and we
will get them open
all right let's uh let's get into this
oh and this is a beautiful super chat
we're reading ministry for the future on
your recommendation thank you great
choice
tremendous book by kim stanley robinson
oh and someone on twitch saying they
watched the accidental president
documentary last weekend in which i am
featured that's great i might have james
the um uh produ the
director producer creator on the show
soon all right let's get into this
anti-mask
incident we had an interesting uh
leopard print anti-massacre recently
who made about 12 wrong allegations
about what was taking place
let's see what happens with this one so
let me ask you
is it a law what's the federal law that
prevents me from learning
so first of all federal law isn't
relevant
uh this masked stuff is being governed
at the state level
she also says what's the law that
prevents me from wearing a mask
and of course there's no federal or
state law preventing
her from wearing a mask did you guys
notice that how she says what law
prevents me this is about she should be
wearing one but she's not
and she says what prevents me from
wearing nobody nothing
so let me ask you is it a law what's the
federal law that prevents me
federal law now who decides
that uh oh i see we're all this isn't
the beginning
who even decides that like why does she
get to decide that the problem is
federal law
let's keep let's go now to the beginning
[Music]
would it surprise you to know this
woman's an attorney but she does child
custody so she wouldn't know about mask
law that's a joke by the way
store policy i can't ask you to leave
okay
so let me ask you is it a law
what's the federal law that prevents me
from learning this
facebook federal law not
federal okay so you don't know so it
sounds like her
legal framework is one of federal
supremacy
interesting i wonder what other legal
scholarship
she's taken positions on state order
the state order no no no the law
state laws are laws law because
i'm going to get your badge number and
i'm going to see you as well
okay okay so what is the business can't
ask you to leave for any reason
that prevents me from that now the
officer i mean listen
i'm not saying the officer is wrong in
what he's saying the officer is right
the it's not even a question of the of
the law stores can have policies
it's not quite any reason there are
protected classes
so in the in all 50 states you can't say
we don't serve black customers here we
don't serve jewish customers here
we don't serve customers born in a
certain country in some states
you can refuse service based on real or
perceived
sexual or gender identity that's bonkers
that's cuckoo for coco puffs
but it's it's so the officer is i mean
for the the purposes of this discussion
the officer is right
they don't have to provide you service
do they do
they serve the public so this is this is
this public accommodation thing
that some of the anti-massacres have
been talking about it's legally
irrelevant
why do i pose any threat
medically or physically not
doesn't have to be over a threat they
have a policy here
they're following this they're following
the state mandate
it's not man you have an idea i think
the ques i mean listen
see the tough thing about these is like
different officers will choose to engage
at different levels at some point it
would be a relevant question to say
why do you think that laws have to be
federal
uh most of the law that we are bound by
is state law
yes there are federal crimes that some
most people's interactions with justice
systems are state
systems and very few people are
challenging in fact it's more common
people challenge
federal the supremacy of federal law
most people do the opposite of what she
does
it is a mandate and law two different
things
this is private property no no no no do
they
serve the public okay what do you need
to her yes do you have your ideas no no
no no
i'm not giving you my id okay
now it's time to go
[Music]
can you imagine relax you can keep
going all you want but we're going to
put put it in your purse
[Music]
touch my phone don't touch don't touch
my phone i'm oh i'm relaxed come on
let's walk out let's walk out
oh
now at this point she's resisting right
like is there any situation
in which a black man resists in this way
and isn't down on the ground already
do do any of us disagree about that like
did this
you know resisting arrest is this ruse
that's used just to take anybody down
this this is resisting if i've ever seen
it resisting
ah stop resisting i like that
you are pulling away from us that is
resistant you are trying to get free
who like and i get it i'm not i don't
want her body slammed to be clear
she's she's the one dragging these
officers around that is resisting
oh i can't wait to see you right now hey
i
can't wait to see your ass yeah i'm sure
a lawyer will be really up for this one
oh i can't wait to see your ass i want
to provide
ideas
do they provide services it doesn't
matter give me
give me my cell phone stop pulling away
from us no no
give me my cell phone pulling away from
us is responsible no no no give me my
cell phone
give me everything is recorded
now everything's being recorded give me
my cell phone
missed everything's being released be
myself just put your hands behind your
back
oh god you're more fun aren't you
missing
just put your hands behind your back oh
it was she got a purse
let go of your purse oh no one's a butt
where's my cell phone she does sound
drunk like i would i don't know what
what ended up happening with this case
but it wouldn't be shocking if she got a
lawyer who said listen she's struggling
with alcohol
and she was she was she was just drunk
we've got it all right where's my cell
phone i have your cell phone
i want my cell phone thank you give me
my cell phone now
my cell phone now
oh i can't wait to see the [ __ ] out of
you who talks to police this way by the
way
how are you going to sue anyone oh
absolutely i know you're the one
where's my cell phone cell phone
[Music]
oh absolutely thank you
oh dicks you know you're the one being
dead
oh the illegal sir
you can't have the person oh my god he's
gonna go to jail legal
illegal i'm not super hurts i want your
first
illegal
[Applause]
this is crazy how is this where we are
as a country where people are doing this
i want my cell phone now i'm putting
this in your purse
people have been maced and tasered for
less there's absolutely no question
whatsoever about that
i want my cell phone now
she got this thing wrapped around her i
want my
cell phone you're not gonna see it all
the time you want
i want my cell phone now i have to break
the first i want to break through i'm
going to add high coffee you're going to
fight with me
you are so in trouble i'm not
so in trouble i'm not you are oh no no
no no no
no don't fight with us i'm going to take
yourself
i wasn't fighting for with you at all
the whole place seen it oh dude
you are so in trouble i'm not worried
about it
it's like what did what did the cops do
that could even be plausibly
wrong here what would you like what
would you even say the cops did that's
wrong
no okay i want my cell phone now
don't put your there you go thank you
what are you taking my cell phone for
i'm gonna put it in your purse all right
then give me my purse you know your
purse is sitting up with us
put your hands behind your back
there you go uh you guys are so happy
can you
watch it see look at put yourself in
there yeah i don't know you know there's
people who will say
when we watch these that these are sort
of like psychotic episodes or fugue
states
i i don't know about that like i think
that some of these are personality
disorder things we
i interviewed a psychiatrist about it
and so with some of these folks it's
like this is
they're sort of like this all the time
it's a personality disorder
oh and true no worries that's not mine
i mean she also seems drunk
is there see mine in my pocket i want to
see it i want to see it
you go through my cell phone
i like the door closing as she's saying
i guess you're a dead man or something
like that
let me get them write a statement yeah
oh man
okay all right so there's that that is
something else yeah
it's oh man it's it's
it's not it's not good um oh let me see
what this is uh
newsmax talking about bill gates wants
people on synthetic beef deal
john bachman filling in for chris
sullivan been a lot of fun maybe i'll be
back tomorrow hopefully not though
hopefully the weather will clear up so
chris can get back to work
join us right back here at five o'clock
eastern we'll break down all the day's
biggest news
and more spicer and company is headed
your way next
sean spicer has a show on newsmax yeah
we'll stay tuned for a little bit of
that that's pretty interesting stuff
okay thanks to david cohen for signing
up at joinpakman.com as well as jeffrey
moffitt
members 49 and 50 today they used the
coupon code
perfect coupon code better21 absolutely
love it also thank you to
[Music]
gocairo for signing up via twitch prime
i appreciate that putting us at 51
and uh oh also thanks to christopher
bernstein
for signing up at joinedpakman.com
appreciate that
okay i've got technical difficulties on
fox news clips to go over with you guys
um i also want to look at some super
chats
being a karen is now a psychological
disorder david skye reminds me of this
from the a team okay i'm not going to
click on that right now
i just looked this auntie masks woman
name is actually karen
um white people do this david black
people know we would be beaten or killed
yikes i find it interesting how the cops
don't pull a gun on her for resisting
arrest like mentioned early david
imagine if she was a black man
bad faith interview seth weather is
called out by bbc for disinformation
and claims the news anchor is triggered
oh that sounds
that sounds interesting oh i like this
too when i worked security at a
nightclub the people who were the worst
to throw out were arrogant drunk lawyers
dropping their jd
bad flashbacks red wine is a hell of a
drug
yes yes to all of it all right let's see
what's up with this
quickly but was it really an exoneration
uh clearly i mean the reality was it
wasn't even a real impeachment which is
why the uh the head of the supreme court
refused to sit over the trial
no that's not no that's not true that's
definitely not true of the trial because
he only presides when
a pres sitting president is there that
is not that is effect this guy you can
already tell this guy is not going to
like being fact-checked
very separate issue from whether
impeachment goes ahead or not
you know that the senate voted 56 to 44
to let the trial continue you can carry
on but when you make a statement like
that i jump in seth all yours
i'd love for you to jump in the reality
is the constitution makes it very clear
that you cannot impeach
someone who is not a sitting president
that is totally untrue
we're not going to keep talking about it
no because you can talk
you just get to talk over me well i get
to i get to correct
when you make either a misstatement or
he's the host
a statement this guy is getting a lesson
in how tv works
it needs clarification that's how it
works when you come on to the bbc
i ask a question you answer it if you
make a misstatement i jump in
anytime i want so can we carry on and
not yes
the host is the decider this is such a
funny thing
yeah the host has control talking about
the unconstitutionality of it can we
talk
about what donald trump will do now seth
can you talk about what donald trump
will do now do you want to discuss what
happened
or do you want to talk over me when i
make statements so you're the decider of
what is
fact you're the constitutional scholar
of the constitution the united states of
america
you know all and that's this is a dig at
the guy being british by the way
you get to correct me and shut me up on
air if i say something you disagree with
okay the reality is you cannot impeach a
sitting of someone that's not a sitting
president that's obviously untrue
the constitution makes that clear which
is why they say the purpose is to remove
a president from office and potentially
to bar them from holding office in the
future
which they never mention whenever
they're pressed on this issue
that's all the point i'm trying to make
i don't know why that said i get that
and i think you also know and just let
me speak you also know
that the senate voted the other way to
let that trial continue now we know you
disagree with that but they did
vote let's just talk about today okay 57
to 43.
that included seven republican senators
does it sting
to have them vote against president
former president trump
no it doesn't sting at all i mean the
kind of people that voted against him
are little weasels like ben
sass and others mitt romney etc who
these are people that if they were to
have an election
anytime soon in their state specifically
someone like ben sasse
he realized mitt romney would easily be
reelected in utah
so he had to hedge a little bit and say
especially ben sasse
they're very likely going to lose that
re-election and these are people that
have just had they they've had it out
for donald trump from before he became
president from the tommy first ran
they've hated him they're established
romney didn't have it out for true
romney met with trump and was willing to
be his secretary of state then trump
picked someone else and romney was like
i guess he doesn't want me that's so
not true like the republican party the
people in the base
they don't we don't like these people dc
likes them the media likes them
uh that's pretty much it and so again
these are people that are not going to
be in sound situations when it comes to
re-election
i think mitt romney is going to do fine
guys and
again everything about this was a farce
there is
no legitimacy to it both sides of the
house
you did say that let me move on uh
donald trump talked about moving on with
make america great again
does he want to get back into active
politics
i think he's going to be very active
when it comes to 2022 and supporting
people
that uh were opposed to him whether it
be in this impeachment or other areas
and that specifically speaking as to
republicans
uh and so i do think we'll be involved i
don't personally really believe he's
going to run in 2024 i think he would
rather
in essence use the the fear of him
potentially running for other
republicans to kind of keep that
position open
and then eventually be able to be a king
maker on whoever that individual
ultimately is and i do think he will
have a king maker role in that
seth we did get there in the end and it
was interesting
next time we could have a mortgage back
all right we'll we'll try it again next
time all right so i mean this guy's
annoying but sort of
not not super remarkable but definitely
definitely interesting
okay let me just listen a little bit to
what sean spicer's program is on newsmax
but then i do have clips i wanted to go
over with you guys hold on
when you need them walls cops everything
else then they're great
when you don't need them they're bad and
they should all be taken away but it's
funny because remember when president
trump wanted to use the guard
and use those troops to secure the city
and other federal sites
it was abhorrent that was horrible until
they wanted to do it
absolutely and it shows the the really
the two different standards
i mean the white house was under siege
the president had to go into protection
within the white house it almost fell
um they called out the national guard
and the mayor and even the leadership of
the democrats funny because
they've never admitted that the white
house perimeter almost fell
when trump went into the bunker trump
said he was in the bunker to like
examine the bunker inspect it or
something and that everything was fine
now this guy's saying no no it was very
close to security falling
the guard it's unbelievable the way that
they will point fingers of blame and at
the same time
uh criticize those who exercise
authority yeah
you know we saw 26 000 national guard
troops come into
the capital for inauguration and as sean
mentioned there's
over 5 000 of those troops still here um
are you on board with that because
there's reports that they might be here
into the fall
well i think this is absolutely just
imagery that nancy pelosi wants you know
we're we're a democracy
we're not afraid of our electorate the
the democrats right now are running a
narrative of fear
so this is um in the public this is
really uh
people who support donald trump and now
as you okay this is this is
all quite dumb in the sense that uh
this is just newsmax um continuing to to
just cover stories
that are really not the important
stories um
what has been going on with republican
obstruction when it comes to coronavirus
40 of deaths under trump's watch were
preventable
there's a there's a dozen stories that
are more important stories the national
guard
troop story okay i mean yeah maybe it's
a story and they're starting to slowly
reduce the number of troops and they
wanted to have troops there through
impeachment because it was unclear
whether
there were going to be more attempts at
insurrectious
activity like yeah i mean but we want to
get the troops out eventually but the
idea that this is this is like the story
they've been they've been pushing this
for a while
all right let me get to some you guys
know that i love
technical errors on right wing media
and yesterday everybody was losing their
connection
on tucker carlson's program and um
the explanations from tucker were all
pretty wild
let's take a listen to this first one
with uh rick perry here
so i i love texas
don't want to attack texas on the other
hand the most basic responsibility of
government you'd think is to keep the
power
on especially when people needed to
survive they didn't why
[Laughter]
i should say that rick perry is in texas
right it sounded like he was in space
but he's not he's in texas he has no
power
that's being run i think on a generator
right
he's proving the point that we're making
governor we're going to put you on hold
for a second okay so
it must be it must be the texas power
situation right
no because then they go to ron desantis
who's in florida
and the exact same things happen ever
says that out loud i mean how could you
ignore something
that the data show
oh i'm afraid we've lost governor
desantis
can you hear me governor i can't hear
oh i'm sorry about that i can hear the
governor he cannot hear me i just want
to say for the record that unlike as in
texas tonight
i think the power is still on in florida
fewer windmills uh in the state than
there are in texas so
that's the good news but for some reason
the governor couldn't hear us
you know what this reminded me of i
actually i i don't know why i love that
i this reminded me of some of my
absolute
favorite clips of one of trump's last
rallies before the election
where there were there was constant uh
there there were actually two clips
there was constant feedback you guys
know i love these clips any
opportunity to play these is it is a
great opportunity that i take let's take
a listen
both of you states goodbye
[Applause]
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
now it's probably a rhino is operating
and then this is probably my favorite uh
technical difficulties
um clip from from any trump rally that i
can remember there was one where he
talked about the teleprompter waving up
and down
but this one's pretty pretty high up
and our there oh these people don't know
what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one time
[Applause]
that is just my that is the best i i
don't know why i love that
and aren't credible oh these people
don't know what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
and then he says don't pay them right
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him there it is
you know i have a reputation for not
paying and it's a false reputation
when somebody does a lousy job it's
false
um okay all right so there is that
uh what on earth help forgotten jews is
an advertiser what is
saying it's okay to have faith
for just 25 you can help supply the
essential foods they
desperately need for one month for
overseas
oh my god it's huckabee you know what
this is guys
there's this crazy um
a lot of a lot of people don't
understand like how are right wingers
both
anti-semitic but they love israel
and see how it says international
fellowship of christians and jews
evangelical christians like mike hack
mike
mike hackaby mike huckabee um
they have these religious beliefs and
excuse me that i don't know exactly what
the dict what the the the scripture is
it's something about if they support
israel
it'll bring jesus back like that's the
super simplified version of it
so they get involved in all of this
um uh uh support of israel that's like
not real
it's not actually about about jews uh
and judaism and and it's crazy but that
was bizarre
that was absolutely bizarre what we just
saw
mike huckabee involved mike hackaby
really really wild stuff
okay i want to get i see the super chats
let me just make sure i've thanked
everybody carlos cruz jr
is a new member and joseph luther has
also
made a pledge via patreon we're going to
count everything because we need it
we're going to count everything because
we need it also thanks to oliver jot
bean product and one other person
for signing up via twitch putting us at
57 people asking about the phones i will
open phones
uh if we get to a hundred otherwise i
think on tomorrow's stream we've got
something pretty interesting cooked up
for tomorrow i think we'll get there
we'll get there tomorrow
um okay all right let me let me see what
people are saying i know
the super chats are coming in good to
see you laugh david support real media
thank you
please play the newsmax bernie sanders
infinity loop error oh i don't know what
that is
let me see newsmax
bernie infinity loop
um newsmax bernie glitch
i can't find i didn't think it was
bernie newsmax
technical difficulties is it this one
mccarthy was there chairman brady that's
a several of us
and uh to hear the heart-wrenching
stories of these
pipeline companies that have to tell
thousands of their their employees
they're now laid off
because of executive orders by this new
president
it is unbelievable what we're seeing and
you're the quote by by bernie sanders
those cicadas are really really really
aggressive okay people saying newsmax
bernie let me see
newsmax bernie oh that is the one that
is the one it was that he mentioned
bernie yeah all right all right
newsmax feed goes haywire
after guest mentions bernie that's
genius
as i mean like obviously it's just a
coincidence but that's pretty damn funny
that's really funny i like that one okay
back to super chats uh giuliani no
longer representing trump in
any legal matters that's not surprising
that's no surprise it was just a matter
of time
this guy reminds me of the onion article
area man
passionate defender of what he imagines
the constitution to be
yes yes
um
otherwise just what a four tier system
we have for law enforcement it's about
the color of your skin and how much you
have in your bank account
right right i mean i think if you are
poor
and not white you get the worst
treatment if you're not white but
wealthy you get significantly better
treatment but not always
remember what happened with that harvard
professor
the the police were called because it
looked like he was breaking into an
expensive house it was his house
um yeah i agree with that it's sort of
like a four quadrant
do you or don't you have money is your
skin white or is it not white
all right very good so good we are
caught up
there as far as that goes
and um oh i'm being told there's
interesting things
in the rudy is no longer representing
trump's story let me
let me find that uh where is that
article
giuliani no longer representing trump
okay good let's take a look at this
let's see what's being reported this is
the first i'm hearing of it i probably
will talk about it tomorrow
giuliani no longer representing trump in
any legal matters
former president trump's personal
attorney rudy giuliani
is not currently representing president
trump in any legal matters senior trump
advisor jason miller
told cnn on tuesday oh let's just see if
we can find the video then because
that's probably
jason miller cnn rudy
rudy trump um
nothing there yet
maybe oh maybe this clip will tell us
what we want see if we can unmute
dater it is also his record the facts 1
and 40
of the nearly 40 lawsuits brought by the
president and republicans to try to
challenge the results of this election
they have only one win
nothing so far altering the vote tally
as for president trump
again no public events on his schedule
today the only thing he's done
publicly of course just tweeted moments
ago saying
uh that he is recommending to the gsa
clearly this is old i don't even know
what this video is it clearly has
nothing to do with the story
even though this was just published
trump's banned from twitter and none of
this makes any sense all right
miller said in a tweet ah here we go
donald trump's longtime personal
attorney rudy giuliani is no longer
working for the former president
according to jason miller in a statement
miller writes mayor giuliani is not
currently representing president trump
in any legal matters
jason miller clarifies simply that there
are no pending cases where mayor
giuliani is representing the president
the mayor remains an
ally and a friend okay i mean does
doesn't seem like necessarily the
biggest uh the biggest news
there what are my thoughts on the
fetterman senate run
i like it i think he's an interesting
guy and i'm uh
i'm very very interested in it all right
let's let's see what's happening now on
newsmax
albert did it so everybody in his
administration was told go
out make change get things done
everybody who worked for donald trump
was given that mandate
rick grinnell did it that's different
there were 5 000 people that were
appointed by this president there were
very few and you among them
that actually got things done and can
stand up and say
check check check that makes you very
different
well thank you again for that but let me
let me just say that i think that
uh anyone who's appointed in any
position needs to ignore the media
ignore what the
criticism is and stick to the vision and
so
i think i just have the ability to
ignore the criticism from the media
it kind of charges me up sometimes
actually maybe it's because i'm a cancer
survivor and
i can kind of get up every day and say i
got one more day let's make it the best
that we can make it today um but just to
answer your question i don't want to be
cute about the governor's race because i
think it's incredibly important
i'm really focused on these long-term
fixes i i think it's really important
that what a disaster
i mean they avoided they avoided a major
technical problem at least
but uh an absolute and total disaster
here's what's coming up from the
standpoint of
uh streams thursday noon
east 9 a.m
west the gamestop
um uh robin hood congressional hearings
i am going to be live with them because
i think it's going to be
absolutely fascinating the ceo of robin
hood is going to be testifying
um i think it's going to be really
really interesting so that's going to be
on
thursday at noon we'll probably start a
little bit before that
um i believe katie porter is not
going to be part of the questioning but
aoc is
maybe chat can correct me on that but
that is uh
that's gonna be that's gonna be
interesting to watch that'll be on
thursday
and then tomorrow we have a couple of
things planned but i don't wanna say
uh too too much yet just because it it
may not happen
all right so that's gonna do it for me
uh for
today we are going to be back uh very
very strongly tomorrow make sure to
subscribe if you're watching on youtube
make sure to follow if you're watching
on twitch we did surpass
uh 79 000 twitch followers we are very
very close to 80. i think we're going to
get there very soon with your help
and i'll see everybody tomorrow